[Musica]
ciao sì e lo tocca tavassi perché tanto
da piano è tanto visto che quelli di
prima sono tipo bravissimi qualche modo
proviamo a false e non c'è da non c'è da
non vergognarsi 12.000 persone sono
messe più o meno così all'isola di lesbo
che è quindi io penso che il punto di
partenza non sia un punto di partenza su
proprio super sereno quindi quando la
man detto tadic se ho detto devo
ispirare le persone poi ho detto voi un
ispirato nessun senso che quello che ho
pensato di poter raccontare faccio due
cose faccio l'imprenditore e o una forte
passione del fare formazione no quindi
vado a insegnare un po queste cose però
quelle del marketing dell'economia
quindi le robe negative a in giro per
l'italia un po per il mondo e ho pensato
che la situazione non è poi così
positiva però ho trovato una storia
alles come una metafora interessante opi
è un robottino marziano che è stato
spedito su marte dalla nasa tipo nel
2004 alla sua missione doveva durare
qualcosa come sei mesi dopo circa 15
anni
a un certo punto hobby spedisce questi
due numeri alla alla nasa il primo
numero è l'energia che riesce a
recuperare ancora dai suoi pannelli
solari e il secondo è il fatto livello
di oscurità no il livello di buio che
più o meno c'era stanzialmente hobby fa
capire di essere nella merda perché non
riesce a ricaricarsi e c'è troppo buio
quindi che la nasa dice ma i batteri
sloan venga indiziati in talk quindi
salendo buio fitto
e c'è un bellissimo posto appunto socia
della nasa che dice qua ce n'è più per
hobby e opi si spegne però ha fatto il
suo mestiere e è un po piaciuta sta cosa
perché a me sembra che il pianeta abbia
le batterie quasi scali che però forse
qualcosa possiamo fare ancora io ho
guardato qualche tadic
perché devo preparare vediamo cosa fanno
gli altri così almeno cerco di far meno
peggio di qualcuno ce n'è uno molto
bello di un mio amico che era un
professore di ca foscari che si ma
bloody finotto che a un certo punto
prende questa frase che è di danilo
dolci che è un poeta sociologo è
qualcosa di questo tipo dice c'è chi
educa senza nascondere l'assurdo che nel
mondo aperto ad ogni sviluppo ma
cercando di essere franco all'altro come
s sognando agli altri come ora
ciascuno cresce solo se sognato è
piaciuta molto questa questa fase perché
penso di uno dei nostri compiti sia
quello di sognare gli altri non c'è ma
non di far sognare di aiutarsi a
siringare dei sogni nelle persone questo
credo che sia un messaggio abbastanza
positivo un messaggio che noi viviamo in
un contesto che giusto per incasinarmi
ancora di più volevo citare ci senti mi
hai gol sì c'è una traduzione inglese
non un trick per dirlo con parole
inglese sa impossibile a una uno
studioso ungherese che a un certo punto
teorizza sta cosa teorizzare questo
questo sistema del flop guidice quando
una cosa da sai fare bene e per quanto
difficile sia tu lo sai fare tanto bene
no quindi più alta è la tua competenza
più alta è la difficoltà di quella cosa
tu entri in un momento di epifania che
chiamiamo il floro entri in sta cosa
qualcuno nello sport avrà l'avrà sentita
chiamare tesoro ente in una zona in cui
in qualche modo stai benissimo
e a me è successo facendo il pane tv
dopo due anni faccio il padre viene bel
pane entrò nel flo del pane fantastico e
capisco che sta cosa della del flow
degli obiettivi è una cosa che comunque
ritornano tanto nei misteri tasco di
raggiungere gli obiettivi lo fa la
maratona in 254
tant'è che scopro questa parola che si
chiama beamon esca beamon è un
personaggio che nel 68 a città del
messico un certo punto fa le
qualificazioni per il salto in lungo il
giorno delle qualificazioni sbaglia due
salti su tre rischia di non andare alla
finale delle olimpiadi
il giorno dopo pare anche che sono
avesse fatto for serata ci sono degli
aneddoti su questi lui salta 894 una
cosa che già ne 890 i giudici non
riescono a certificare il salto perché
avevano settato il misuratore ott 50 e
record precedente era 834 ha detto tanto
nessuno salta più di otto e mezzo questa
quasi 9 metri sostanzialmente aspettano
45 minuti bloccano la gara che non
trovano un metro di quelli da sarto
misurano 890 questo vince l'oro
olimpiadi e nasce questa parola che è
beamon esca a me però ha molto colpito
sta cosa perché a un certo punto p moon
misti a fare il sociologo il filo
cambiamenti
e dice si è fidata quel salto la però
sapete dopo quell'epifania quel flo quel
momento io tutto sommato ne sono pure
dimenticato e mi sembra un po che noi
viviamo dentro questo mondo qua un mondo
in cui raggiunto un obiettivo ce n'è
subito un altro che ci corre dietro e
siamo ossessionati dalla mania del tasc
con l'obiettivo non ce lo godiamo magari
perché forse non è tanto il fatto di
settare continuamente obiettivi ma di
avere un obiettivo che è quello di
migliorarsi un po questo potrebbe essere
un sistema che secondo me potrebbe
andare un po me la società centrata sul
lavoro è morta ma non sappiamo come
seppellirla questa è l'apertura di un
libro e un sociologo chiama ricolfi ok
che ha scritto la società signorile di
massa voi ricordatevi che quando
torturati i numeri i numeri dicono
quello che vuoi quello che volete voi e
dove ne porto uno di un numero 55 mila
euro due terzi delle famiglie italiane
composte da italiani che vivono in
italia hanno a disposizione 55.000 euro
di reddito l'anno da poter investire ne
spendono tipo 40mila viviamo in una
società ricca due terzi delle famiglie
italiane sono ricche perché la società
signoria di massa perché è una società
ricca ma morta
stiamo usando i soldi della nonna stiamo
vivendo con l'a ppartamento della nonna
che ci ha lasciato con l'affitto di
quella roba la questa società non
produce più reddito consumo reddito ma
un sacco di soldi perché voi ogni volta
sentite che l'olandese fa pure bene
incazzarsi questi soldi non ve li do
perché abbiamo un sacco di risparmio
privato grande tema politico però c'è un
tema dentro sarà vacua l'italia è per
buona parte dei suoi soldi da parte del
suo sistema mediamente ricca ok quindi
viviamo in una società signorine di
massa e viviamo in una società che
giudica a un certo punto de botton che è
un filosofo dice difficile ricordarsi
della morte quando si sa da fare non è
tanto un tabù quanto una cosa
improbabile persona tura il lavoro non
ci lascia scelta viene preso sempre
troppo sul serio funzioniamo sulla base
di una miopia necessaria consiste in
questo la pura e semplice energia
dell'esistenza la volontà ceca non meno
impressionante di quella della falena
che faticosamente attraversa il davanti
girando intorno a una goccia di pittura
sfuggita un pennello frettoloso
rifiutandosi di considerati vostro
disegno della realtà
in base alla quale sarà morta al calare
della notte io ho messo un immagine e
sergio marchionne c'è un bel libro di
tommaso abarth su di un certo punto
viene fuori che ogni volta che torna a
questa immagine proprio sui social di
cui si parlava prima si c'è ma
marchionne non s'è goduto i figli non ha
vissuto la vita che la vita giusta
questa tonalità sbagliata ha lavorato
troppo il mio
la mia idea è quella che forse avrebbe
vissuto la vita che voleva vivere in
penso che noi stiamo vivendo oltre che
da gol people da persone con troppi
obiettivi con troppe obiettivi settati
stiamo vivendo giudicando un po troppo
questo è il pensiero che ho io e faccio
io faccio il marketing non faccio quel
mestiere per cui qualcuno ha detto alla
gente felice non consuma quindi se voi
siete felici io ho sbagliato lavoro
questo è il primo il problema principale
che mi porta dietro usa perché lo
sappiate nel 2000 una delle più
importanti multinazionali del tabacco ha
spedito 13 milioni di folder sini per i
libri negli stati uniti ai bambini
dicendogli ricordati che fumare una cosa
da grandi quindi non pensare a fumare
pensaci non fumare
ok lo ri pratica i bambini i ragazzini
cosa che vogliono fare vogliono essere
grande quindi è il peggior messaggio
subliminale no che possiamo in qualche
modo portare io faccio quella roba
l'acqua il mestiere superski forze però
all'interno di questo mestiere imparato
delle cose e mi piacerebbe provare
condividerle con voi
la prima cosa che ho imparato è che
quando noi sentiamo dire il made in
italy questo sogno italiano che torna
perché siamo più bravi degli altri non è
vero niente
secondo me non è assolutamente vero che
noi siamo più bravi degli altri perché
in qualche questa è una foto di hanoi è
una delle cose che ho portato a casa è
la storia in qualche modo del sarto di a
noi no
certo di noi è un personaggio che più o
meno come il sarto di ferrara o rovigo
che dove dove vengo io a una diversa
grinta una diversa gara in qualche modo
il sarto di anodi cui può cucire un
vestito sartoriale in una giornata come
un atto con in qualche modo vi prende le
misure quello manda a casa il giorno
dopo che lo spedisce ok
e se voi volete vi farò anche pagare con
paypal ma il problema del sarto diano e
rispetto a salto di treviso che non è
poi così vero che quel made in italy
quella roba l'hai così migliore perché
il sarto di a noi fa dei vestiti figli
ok quindi quello da cui noi dobbiamo in
qualche modo secondo me è scappare o
comunque in cui sicuramente guardarsi
bene le spalle è il fatto che viviamo in
un contesto globale in cui questo film
questo sogno dell'italia che funziona
non funziona più
noi dobbiamo pensare di vivere in un
contesto in cui i fuoriclasse li ha
chiamati così mal con blood on in un
libro molto bello gli outlier cioè la
ferrari non possono essere quello che dà
da mangiare a tutti
ok per ogni outlier per ogni ferrari per
ogni estrema eccellenza ci sono là fuori
99 persone in realtà aziende che non ce
la fanno e secondo me è quello che
dobbiamo guardare perché probabilmente
se noi continuiamo anche a disegnare dei
sogni di questo tipo molto probabilmente
stiamo anche disilludendo qualcuno e io
come invece omaggio ferrara voglio
raccontarvi più in maniera almeno
secondo me è più interessante la storia
di un'azienda di gorom ok e questa
azienda è il più grande importatore nel
mondo di stoccafisso anche qui o che i
dati che ci fregano perché lo
stoccafisso lo mangiano solo gli
italiani portoghesi quindi più grande
importatore perché italiano perché lo
mangiano italiani stoccafisso baccalà
che dir si voglia anche se uno è sotto
solo uno è sotto sale quindi non è
proprio la stessa cosa e rivas mark che
questa azienda fondata da luca che non
mio dal papà di luca che un mio caro
amico di ferrara e è un'azienda che
funziona è un'azienda che fa di quella
non tanto saper fare ma di quel
distretto di quelle con sistema di
quell'economia fa qualcosa che funziona
secondo me più che sugli outlier sui
fuoriclasse sugli obiettivi sull'ansia e
su queste cose qua che dobbiamo puntare
e su queste cose dove abbiamo davvero un
vantaggio competitivo che non è solo un
vantaggio competitivo
effettivo perché anche ferrari ce l'ha
ma è un vantaggio competitivo scalabile
perché in fianco a riva mar
esiste un'altra azienda che può fare la
stessa cosa perché il distretto può
funzionare
secondo me sono queste ancora le cose
sulle quali noi dobbiamo in qualche modo
pensare di portare a casa valore questo
dato è il rapporto negli anni tra lo
stipendio dell'amministratore delegato e
lo stipendio dell'ultimo dei dipendenti
negli stati uniti quindi nel 65 un
amministratore delegato il capo
dell'azienda guadagnava 20 volte suo
ultimo dipendenti nel 89 lo guadagnava
61 volte tanto oggi guadagna 320 volte
tanto io no ovviamente sotto pressione
che lo possa dire il tema quale però il
tema è che la disparità la
disuguaglianza il contesto del lavoro
complesso estremamente complicato in un
contesto in cui un un autore ha scritto
un libro parlato di bush jobs i lavori
di merda ok ne vuole di merda
ricordatevi che non sono quei lavori che
possono rappresentare per molti volti
sembra i lavori estremamente umilino
pulire i bagni o qualcosa del genere
sono cose secondo me è super
interessanti il problema dei lavori di
merda sono lavori che per cui lo stessa
persona che di fa percepisce la totale
inutilità degli stessi è provato che in
39 per cento degli impiegati americani
fanno lavori che attengono al lavoro di
un altro quindi sono in una riunione
stanno controllando i task la checklist
il lavoro il sistema quello che stanno
facendo gli altri fanno cose inutili ok
quindi esce crescono tantissimo questo
tipo di lavori in cui le persone si
tengono occupate ma capiscono di star
facendo un lavoro inutile secondo me
siamo in un contesto in cui
effettivamente lo speaker precedente mi
ha dato l'assist
abbiamo sicuramente rubato il futuro una
generazione hanno rubato anche a me io
penso che sia mia zia lupin è andata in
pensione a 35 anni che però qualcuno al
futuro gli è stato rubato
io quello che io posso fare quello che
ho pensato di fare dando lavoro a 35
persone orgogliosamente rovigo è
semplicemente cercare di impostare un
sistema in cui più o meno tu puoi
chiedere fare infinite in cui tu puoi
lavorare da dove vuoi
in cui tu puoi fare poi se misurato sui
tuoi risultati e non
sugli orari di lavoro che hai ok e in
cui sei anche estremamente stimolato in
un contesto super sfidante super
incazzoso perché sono gli altri che ti
giudicano i tuoi pari e non tanto una
situazione gerarchica e sei super
stimolato cercare in qualche modo di
fare bene io dico sempre ai miei ragazzi
a prestito impegno ma ti pago per i tuoi
risultati
io penso che noi dobbiamo provare a fare
a costruire un contesto un pochino più
interessante un pochino migliore anche
in ottica di società e credo che la
parola che è un po racchiude tutto
questo sia responsabilità quindi secondo
me dobbiamo passare da una società del
controllo non società della
responsabilità ma anche ad una società
probabilmente un pochino meno
ossessionata questa è la sensazione che
io mi sono chiesto e vado a chiudere
come si fa
sta roba è secondo me il come si fa a
ruota attorno a tre grandi moli la
perversione nella nostra era consiste
nel far passare l'eccezione per la
regola il primo mondo il primo tema è
quello che siamo molto portati a
guardare le eccezioni invece dobbiamo
guardare le regole di più il sarto di
più l'importatore di baccalà e un
pochino meno la ferrari perché la
ferrari
lebron james michael jordan 1 cena ok
quindi probabilmente costruire modelli e
sogni scuola roba là a mio parere a un
pochino difficile e c'è un filosofo che
camminava si chiama turo certo punto gli
ho detto c'è gente che crede che sia
vanitoso che mi mette al di sopra degli
altri canti sempre vittorie sappiano
queste persone che se avessi abbastanza
coraggio mi metterei a raccontarlo una
storia e patetiche su di me come lo
faccio su di loro
la lista delle mie debolezze
sufficientemente lunga da incoraggiarli
potrei anche elencare difetti tanto
ripugnanti da offendere il cielo
sappiano dunque che io penso più male di
me di quanto non potranno mai fare loro
io dico io non ho la toga quindi vi dico
vi chiedo vi consiglio di giudicare un
po meno questo sarebbe la pensata che
voglio proporre io se chi sta bene non
fa stare meglio chi sta male prima o poi
chi sta male fa stare peggio chi sta
bene quindi l'ultimo appunto forse
quello di pensare anche un po di
ridistribuire per evitare che tutto
questo ci sono indietro
grazie
[Applauso]